should he be banned I mean damn dude
when you're tweeting out [ __ ] that's
arguably leading stuff like January 6th
I can understand why because it's like
what else is this while I'll do go to
tweet out like is he going to start
instigating other violent events so I'm
sympathetic towards the like okay well
he can't just be here saying stuff like
this that's insane we're gonna ban him
um some of those instigating yeah your
Instagram
violence in the physical world yeah like
if I would have tweeted stuff like that
I would get banned probably on the flip
side this is the president of the United
States it seems like he's like doing
presidential decree by social media
sometimes like is it really right that
one public or private I should say one
private company can um like erase the
president of the United States words
from the eyes of a lot of Americans that
are using these social media feeds
um and one big one which I for sure am
against is the permanent ban yeah I
don't like that I hate that even in my
community if somebody comes back there
for like a year like I mean did you just
compare yourself to the president of the
United States no I found myself to
Twitter Banning the president United
States let me put it this way if I ban
Donald Trump and my chat room I don't
ban them in a year
a year yeah what's the process for
unbanning Donald Trump what would he
have to do usually people send me an
email they're like listen I did this
stuff I'm sorry I was dumb I'll give
them another chance but a year what if
they send an email a month later usually
I'll learn better that's actually my pop
I ban pretty quickly my community but if
you ever ask you're a big softy okay I
usually let them back yeah I'm Fair well
because I used to be the worst type of
Internet person and I think I'm a little
bit better than I used to be so not that
you're older yeah now that I've matured
yeah of course age bestows a wisdom that
just can't be gotten any other way